a few years ago in order to get
respectable power from a gaming laptop
it needed to be big and bulky and even
the largest gaming laptops couldn't come
close to competing with their desktop
counterparts
well now that gaming laptops are using
desktop class GPUs that's all beginning
to change origin PCs Evo 15s for
instance represents a powerful but
portable solution does it make
compromises in the name of portability
well yes but there's still a lot to like
about it let's get into it for a gaming
laptop the Evo 15s is very thin at 0.7
inches it's also relatively light
weighing just four pounds the laptop
uses a 15.6 inch IPS display which
offers vivid accurate colors and wide
viewing in the native 1080p resolution
is great for a gaming laptop this side
laptop features a mostly gloss finish
which looks nice but can attracting
offense the keyboard uses
run-of-the-mill chiclet style keys which
feel competent to type and game on it
also offers RGB backlighting across
three colors own a trackpad responds
pretty well though we would have
preferred a dedicated left and right
click buttons to prevent accidental
clicks the chassis is mostly made of
plastic which results in some minor
undesirable flexing when we gamed on the
notebook the typing surface never got
hot but it did get moderately loud
portable gaming notebooks usually don't
offer a lot of ports but the evil 15s
delightfully surprises here the laptop
offers a plethora of connections that
include three USB 3.0 ports a mini
display fourth HDMI port and more it has
enough ports for either the oculus rift
or HTC vive which makes it a great
portable VR system on the go perhaps our
biggest gripe with the design is the
placement of the power button which is
situated to the front right of the
chassis you may inadvertently turn off
the computer if you're not being careful
the brains behind the laptop is Intel's
quad core i7 7700 HQ CPU which can turbo
up to 3.8 gigahertz the mobile processor
is paired with 16 gigabytes of ddr4 Ram
clocked at 2400 megahertz
Nvidia's GeForce GTX 1060 drives the
graphics here
it's a great GPU that pairs well with
the panel's 1080p resolution for storage
the Evo 15s uses Samsung's high-end SM
961 nvme SSD you can get it and either
256 or 512 gigabytes guarantee our unit
features the latter it's also
supplemented by a happy 2 terabyte 5400
rpm hard drive overall the system specs
are well balanced and represent a
moderately high-end rig we're going to
benchmark the Evo 15 s alongside HD to a
17-inch Omen gaming laptop which is
equipped with a gtx 1070 i7 6700 HQ and
16 gigabytes of RAM while The Omen uses
a slightly older skylake CPU because it
is significantly bigger and equipped
with a higher tier GPU you shouldn't
expect the same level of performance
it's here to give you a point of
comparison for our benchmarks we ran all
games at the respective max settings at
1080p to really stress test the system
our performance data shows that the evil
15s should be able to max out most games
at 1080p with playable framerates
running the lives of the Tomb Raider
benchmark with graphics settings maxed
out origin pcs laptop was able to run
over 60 average fps and more graphically
demanding games like the division and
Metro last light it did dip into the 40s
and 50s but was still highly playable
the laptop couldn't max out Deus Ex
mankind divided though which is one of
the most graphically demanding games on
the market we tried to max out i toast
montreal stealth action game the evil
15s barely made it over 10 FPS the
laptop was able to run the benchmark at
57 average FPS when we disabled
anti-aliasing and lowered the game to
its high preset though when we ran valve
steamvr benchmark the origin PC laptops
produced nine thousand four hundred
eighty seven frames which not only makes
it v already but puts it in the high
tier while the Allman's faster GPU
allows it to pull ahead in games the evo
15s a speedier nvme SSD allows it to
beat HP's notebook in sequential read
and write tests by 115 and 442 percent
respectively
this means Origen laptop really kills it
whenever you need to transfer large
files according to our Cinebench CPU
test evil 15s is 16 percent faster than
single threaded applications and
percent faster in multicolored workloads
these tests indicate that origin PCs
laptop make it a stronger productivity
workhorse in the HP omen for battery
tests we looped the graphically
demanding Unigine value benchmark until
the laptop keeled over this represents a
worst-case gaming scenario here
origins laptop lasted roughly an hour
which isn't great you're most likely
want to bring the charger with you if
you intend to game on the go while you
can find gaming laptops that are more
powerful there's a lot to like about the
evil 15s for a gaming notebook it's thin
light offers a surprising amount of
ports in terms of specs it offers a ton
of those and whistles and should be able
to max that most games at 1080p its
biggest hurdle is its $2,300 price tip
you're really paying for the portable
form factor here it's size and weight
aren't big priorities for you you're
looking for something to lug around to
land parties something like the omen
might be more up your alley HP 17 inch
gaming laptop might be nearly twice as
heavy but you can get it with a more
powerful GTX 1074 around $1,800 if you
have the money and want good specs and a
sleek form factor though origin pcs Evo
15s should definitely be on your radar
for the full written review head on over
to GameSpot calm and if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to us on youtube thank you for watching
you